穴をよく言われるんですけどもうるさいとか近所の人大丈夫ですかとか言われるんです
けどもその辺は安全ですご安心ください統一もですよ実はローゲンなどれづらい
うるさいかっていうのは僕自身あまりわかってないんですねまで結構いろんなでかい音
のするものを使ってきたんですけどもうそれが実際どれくらいのとかっていうのは独自
あんまり終わってないんでしょ好きな今日僕は一体ロック
雷雲際のかっていうのをちょっと自分で感じてみようと思いますねこちらは準備しまし
たあけちゃったんだけどねこれはね欲しかった
そろそろ秋 the 奴が本これさぁこういう男だこういうのをやめて欲しいよねした
したしたこちらですフィッシャーさん g minor これは何をするものかといい
ますと見てもらうと分かるとにを頭の大きさを測るもので今日はこれ今日はこれを使っ
て4型地震が入ってどれくらいうるさいのいろんな1のうるささをつとこれで端れれば
いいなと思っておりますこれで音がわかるだけはどれくらいうるさいかっていうのは
してるんだーっ
もう今のもっとでかいですからねでも叫ぶ声がどれぐらいの大きさが来るかわかんない
から下がってみるじゃないんですよ起きたぞえおつきましたよこういうだけですね僕が
しゃべっている間も常にそれがどれくらいのことかっていうのが分かりますここに書い
てある dba という単位をですねえっと実際の短角に近いうるささの表記の仕方
らしいですれしベットがいろんなその音のた
言われると思うんですけどもこの dba で奴はちょっといろいろ難しいことが書い
てるんですけども簡単には雑音の強さということになるみたいですねうん
すげー勉強になったの騒音レベルと言われているみたいです日常生活の一般的な騒音
レベル
めっちゃ静かな中0ほとんど何も聞こえない呼吸音が重機の擦れ合う音とかで20とぞ
館の中
た静かな住宅街のお昼とか40から45
静かな事務所木々のざわめきが5060db が通常会はこれがまあ普通の生活音
レベルのせいで想像し事務所電話のベルが70地下鉄車内が80ここまで来ると
うるさい騒々しい工場声が90度散布って雪像のガード下が100ここまで来るとき
止めてうるさいらしいですねオートバイのあの発信するふーん鉄が音として聞こえる
限界客28で z 園前の近くとかは立体的苦痛が生じる限界140これが聴力昨日の
限界らしいです結構今大声でしゃべってるんでまぁ80とか9070くらいですねぼく
月にしゃべるとこんなもんですよ目に50を超えるとのうるさい
て感じるんでもう僕は普通に喋ってるだけでも地下鉄車内の音です出せれば z
エンジン超えるんじゃねーかと僕
120こういったとしても音として聞こえる結果になるそういう機能の限界まで迫って
いるということなのでどこまで人の聴力昨日の喧嘩に迫れるかやってみようと思います
猫
まずは軽いこと調べたらでそれでシンバルにどこまで伸びるかやってみましょう
まあそうだと100入ってないまさかあ
大照れで下院で122いかなかって来られたので
を据え張力昨日の限界まではっきり言ってないようで次行ってみます
次防犯ブザーでサブ予想だと客はいけないくらいだと思いますできます
した客車区は言ってましたね客は入ったけどもまぁシンバルぐらいではないのかな
ホセ位
ん
ってみなちゃんこれを待ってたんだろお前なことを願い者が欲しいんだろうな
綺麗だして声で書いたがここで112人超えなかったらもう俺の声デビューし金子
220を超えていただけるとありがたいです
願いしますバスドラム
ああああああ
まあ見てなかった moon
をしぎりぎり入ってない感じがありました俺が今まで食べだってきた奴ら
120すらも言ってないのかこれは悔しいはこんなんでこんなんだよね youtube
盛り上げないのか
まだまだ最後の切り札
では参ります
ばーんわー
おっ
me